meine damen und herren zur leseraktion
der frankfurter allgemeinen
sonntagszeitung heute zum thema miete
ich darf sie ganz herzlich begrüßen mein
name ist corinna budras
wirtschaftsredakteur der frankfurter
allgemeinen sonntagszeitung
und heute in der tat haben wir eine
kleine premiere denn auf so vielen
kanälen wie heute waren wir noch nie
unterwegs was sie da hinten sehen und so
ein bisschen aussieht wie das backoffice
anders spendengala sind tatsächlich zehn
anwälte die übers telefon die fragen
unserer leser beantworten hier neben mir
sitzt herr rolf janssen geschäftsführer
vom mieterverein frankfurt und freut
sich über ihre fragen die sie stellen
können über fasnet über facebook da
unsere webseite und über youtube sie
können aber gerne wenn sie das lieber
bilateral klären wollten mit ihm unseren
10 anmelden
auch anrufen und der der 069 für
frankfurt 75 91 24 und die 50m dran so
dann geht es gleich los hoffentlich mit
fragen die sie regel stellen können ich
würde vielleicht mit von jan janssen zu
beginn einmal hören wie sieht denn ihre
ob sie ein bisschen aus dem nähkästchen
plaudern können sieht denn ihr alltag
aus mit welchen fragen kommen denn die
mieter dazu wir haben jedes jahr über
20.000 beraten die die wir durchführen
und der überwiegende anteil also
deutlich über 30 prozent das sind
nebenkostenabrechnungen gut davon sind
natürlich auch die allermeisten weiter
betroffen und mit einigem abstand kommen
dann fragen zu mängeln der mietsache zum
beispiel wenn die wohnung schimmel
befördert oder die heizung ist
ausgefallen
dann gibt es auch sehr viele beratungen
zu den themen mieterhöhungen verstärkt
in letzter zeit auch das thema
eigenbedarfskündigung durch den
vermieter und natürlich auch alle
anderen themenbereiche sondern sei es
jetzt zum beispiel auch auf fragen zum
mietpreis bremse und alle anderen
bereiche aber der der höchste anteil
sind eben doch die nebenkosten rechnen
zum mietrecht rentner haben sie auch die
eine oder andere fangen denn das ist ja
die frage die jetzt immer politisch
besonders brisant diskutiert wird dabei
auch später in der praxis große rolle
als die mikros bremse eingeführt wurde
hatten wir gedacht na ja vielleicht bist
du jetzt doch sogar den ein oder anderen
zusätzlichen berater einstellen weil so
viele nachfragen kommen
das hat sich überhaupt nicht
bewahrheitet wir hatten in den gang in
der ganzen zeit seitdem die mietpreis
bremse in frankfurt existiert zwei fälle
in denen bei zwei zähler also nicht mehr
was ja für uns auch ein alarmsignal ist
weil das ja bedeutet dass die mietpreis
bremse in der praxis nicht funktioniert
es nicht praxistauglich weil sie viel zu
hoch aufhängen ist denn der große
schwierigkeit für mieter ist ja dass sie
beim vermieter nachfragen müssen wie
hoch ist die vorangegangenen miete
gewesen das machen natürlich die
allermeisten mieter nicht gerne denn
viele haben wochen monate nach einer
wohnung gesucht sind froh überhaupt eine
wohnung gefunden zu haben und möchten
dann nicht direkt zu anfang mit dem
vermieter in eine mit rechtliche
auseinandersetzung geraten
da ist in der tat einer praxis was ja
kein anderer fragt dazu direkt was
spricht denn gegen eine flächendeckende
kreis bremse
also wir befürworten ja auch dass die
minen rasten sie möglichst weit
ausgedehnt aber jetzt nicht nur in den
großstädten und in den ballungsräumen
was allerdings als argument dagegen
gewandelt ist das nicht überall
tatsächlich nicht überall in deutschland
eine angespannte wohnungsmarkt ist es
gibt natürlich gerade im ländlichen
bereiche in denen man durchaus
bezahlbare wohnungen findet und ist auch
gar nicht so schwer ist eine wohnung zu
finden
aber gerade deswegen ist es nötig dass
in den angespannten wohnungsmärkten die
mit gas bremse aber dann offen zu wird
und letztendlich vielleicht weil sie ist
ziemlich deutlich sagt also nicht
überall ist die lage so angespannt dass
heißt weil es eben ein deutlicher
eingriffe ist in die rechte des
vermieters der eben nicht mehr frei die
mieten nach bedarf sozusagen berechnen
kann müsste man damit würden auch sie
sehen müsste man damit vorsichtig sein
allerdings muss man auf folgende sehen
die gepresste bedeutet hat der vermieter
kann eine miete verlangen ortsübliche
vergleichsmiete zuzüglich zehn prozent
auch drauf das ist ja an sich schon
recht aus können nicht ohne mietpreis
bremse hätten wir ja eigentlich so die
freiheit des fuchs im hühnerstall und
die führten dazu dass das die mieten
durch die decke gehen und da sehen wir
das ding da völlig anders da eine
kappung erfolgt
aber sie sagen im grunde genommen in der
praxis nicht besonders traurig jetzt hat
er die bundesregierung schon erste
vorschläge gemacht wie es weiter gehen
soll können sie die kurz vorstellen zu
sagen
also ein punkt soll neben der sein dass
der vermieter zu bedienende speedfans
oder das gesagt eigentlich sogar zu beim
abschluss der der verhandlung zum
mietvertrag offenlegen muss wie hoch die
vorangegangene miete gewesen ist also
dass er in der pflicht ist mit dieser
information das haben wir für eine ganz
wichtige sache dass eben der mieter von
vornherein weiß greift die bremse oder
darf ich sie nicht wobei da muss
natürlich auch klar gestellt werden
durch die regierung dass das für alle
fälle gelten muss und der vermieter sich
nicht darauf herausreden kann dass er
sagt ich muss diese angabe nicht machen
weil ich selber davon ausgeht dass die
lied price bremse ihr gar nicht greift
also da muss natürlich das ganze auch so
praxistauglich sein dass der mieter
etwas davon hat es das kann zahnloser
tiger sein
jetzt haben wir schon eine persönliche
fälle die ich meine vortragen möchte
einfach kann hagen wolf der kommentiert
zum thema nebenkosten in meinen weg
vertrag steht dass der vermieter die
nebenkosten pauschal abrechnen
das heißt ich bekomme keine jährliche
abrechnung kann ich den widersprechen
oder kann ich eine jährliche abrechnung
einfordern wenn eine pauschale
vereinbart worden ist musste vermieter
tatsächlich nicht konkret über die
nebenkosten abrechnet allerdings da eine
pauschale gezahlt wird kann der
vermieter kann der mieter schon
verlangen da sie genauere informationen
darüber denn er muss ja auch wissen ob
möglicherweise diese pauschale zu hoch
angesetzt ist im umgekehrten fall könnte
der vermieter ja auch hingehen und wenn
er über die nebenkosten abrechnet dann
eine höhere pauschale verlangen wenn
sich aus der nebenkostenabrechnung
ergibt dass die pauschale nicht mehr
ausreicht also da sollte der mieter
durchaus mit dem vermieter noch mal
sprechen und darüber klar sein und dann
am besten
eine aufschlüsselung dann verlangt der
einzelpositionen damit er weiß genau ob
jetzt die betriebskostenpauschale die er
zahlt ob die in einem vernünftigen
verhältnis zu den tatsächlichen kosten
stellen jetzt haben wir den fragen von
uwe brandt bei mir in der wohnung gibt
es erhebliche probleme mit heizung
warmwasser nachdem das miteinander
gekoppelt wurde im januar februar märz
ist ja zehnmal ist zehn mal die heizung
das warmwasser ausgefallen da kann man
dann mieten oder behinderung ankündigen
am besten mit einem einschreiben und
erhält dann ein ausweitenden lava brief
der wohnungsgesellschaft was macht man
in diesem fall von herrn brandt sind die
heizung das warmwasser aus wird das ist
natürlich ein gravierender mangel der
mietsache der auch zu einer
mietminderung berechtigt hier sollte man
und das ist auch wohl geschehen den
vermieter darüber informieren und auch
direkt darauf hinweisen dass man die
miete ab jetzt nur noch unter vorbehalt
und eine genaue mit minderungsquote
sollte dann bricht am besten dann im
schriftlichen sätzen deutlich machen
dass und das ist passiert
es sollte nach sollte nachweisbar sein
damit der vermieter hinterher nichts
sagen kann ich wusste ja von nichts und
dann am wagen punkt kam an welchem punkt
kann man selber eigentlich die miete
mindern also weniger überweisen ohne das
ist ein menschliches gibt einige schon
wenn der mangel da ist wenn die heizung
jetzt für eine halbe stunde ausfällt ist
das natürlich jetzt zwar ärgerlich aber
nicht so relevant als es müsste schon
ein zeitraum sein der dann auch für eine
mietwohnung relevant ist also zum
beispiel ein paar tage und das zum
beispiel nicht jetzt wo es draußen sehr
warm ist sondern es müssen so sein dass
die temperatur in der wohnung deutlich
unter 18 grad
und wie weiß ich wieviel gemindert
werden kann gibt es gibt dazu
rechtsprechung allerdings da warnen wir
davor dass man da ohne rechtlichen rat
selber eine miet - quote ansetzt denn da
kann man leicht zum hoch ansetzen das
sollte man doch im einzelfall immer sich
rechtlichen rat einholen und prüfen
lassen wie hoch die mietminderung
angesetzt werden kann
das kann sehr unterschiedlich sein dass
grenzen prozent das können aber auch 50
prozent sein
je nachdem wie lange diese
beeinträchtigung ist und die karl ist
tatsächlich in der wohnung ist nicht das
sollte man dann zum beispiel auch ein
entsprechendes temperatur protokoll
führen aus dem dann da vorgeht wie viel
grad celsius dann morgens mittags abends
in den einzelnen räumen fahren
mietminderung ist das auch ein thema in
das häufig pärchen normale spiel
das ist auch ein sehr wichtiges
beratungsthema weil es hat er immer zu
tun mit mängeln der mietsache und der
mieter zahlt hier die miete für eine ja
vollkommen intakte mietsache also für
eine wohnung die fehler frei ist und
wenn jetzt mängel vorliegen sei es durch
eine einer ausfall der heizung oder
ausfallen das warmwasser oder aber worte
schimmel befallen oder durch lärmende
nachbarn dann ist das ein grund in
lieder zu melden sie haben schon jetzt
ein paar beispiele genannt was ist dann
sozusagen der klassiker also kommt es
immer wieder zu das ist auch
jahreszeitlich abhängig in der
winterzeit erleben das ja häufig dass
heizungen ausfallen und dadurch dann
eben die die miete gemindert wird auch
in der kühleren jahreszeit haben wir
sehr viele fälle die sich dann auf
schimmelbefall beziehen was so das ganze
jahr über andauert das sind fälle in
denen es zum beispiel beeinträchtigungen
gibt durch durch ruhestörung durch
nachbars und über das ist
andreas kräuter kräuter entschuldigung
kommt gerade mit einem ganz aktuellen
thema erfordert nämlich wir brauchen
endlich eine bodenwert steuern und ich
nehme an da wird er darauf anspielen auf
ein grundsatzurteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes das vor zwei
wochen selbst gestellt die grundsteuer
sowie auch oben wird ist ungerecht muss
also reformiert werden und seitdem ist
eben der bundesregierung die länder die
kommunen in heller aufregung und nach
der geeigneten frauen dies zu tun die
grundsteuer vielleicht für die zuschauer
die das nicht genau kennen ist im grunde
um eine steuer die der vom eigentümer
erhoben wird die er aber um welten auf
das heißt es betrifft letztlich jeden in
deutschland was sagen sie zum thema
bürgerwerkstatt also wir fordern ja auch
dass jetzt eine reform absicht und zwar
dahingehend dass eine reine boden steuer
da geschaffen wir die sozusagen keine
rücksicht darauf nimmt wenn ich hier
über baum das grundstück hat werden dass
deswegen führen sehr wichtig es gibt ja
leider auch spekulanten die darauf
hoffen dass ein unbebautes grundstück an
wert gewinnt und und lassen das
grundstück an der stelle einfach auch
über viele jahre unbebaut was eben auch
dazu führt dass der wohnungsmarkt gerade
in städten wie frankfurt sehr angespannt
ist
er soll dem spekulantentum würde man
einen riegel vorschieben
wenn es eine reine boden stöhr gibt denn
dann würde
zu meinem grundstück ist - davon haben
auf der anderen seite gibt es auch
berechnungen nach dem hervorgeht dass
bei einer rein boden steuer viele mieter
insbesondere das von mehrfamilienhäusern
dann eine geringere grundsteuer zahlen
würden auch das halten wir für sehr
wichtig weil die grundsteuer bei den
nebenkosten abrechnungen regelmäßig eine
der besonders hohen kosten position ist
und die neben die nebenkosten sind ja
letztendlich eine zweite miete und weil
dort sehr hohen kosten abverlangt werden
wir das natürlich sehr gut wenn gerade
eben auch die grundsteuer für viele
mieter gesenkt
[Musik]
es muss die mietvertrag geregelt sein
also im mietvertrag selber müssen ja
eigentlich nur vier komponenten
enthalten sein die mietvertragsparteien
motto wer ist vermieter wer ist meter
dann das mietobjekt dann ab wann wird
angemietet und die miethöhe mehr muss in
einem mietvertrag gesteht ich habe
mietverträge beim mieterschutzverein die
sind auf einem din a5 blatt fest
gerechnet
also wenn in einem solchen mietvertrag
nichts zu den nebenkosten steht muss der
mieter auch kein leben kosten zahlen
wenn allerdings aufgeführt ist dass
nebenkosten zu zahlen sind wird sehr
häufig auf die betriebskostenverordnung
verwiesen und dort steht unter anderem
eben auch die sozialen dienst zu
passieren jeder lücken braucht einen
kranken wird mit eigentumswohnungen
inzwischen gefüllt
also was frankfurt anbelangt da hat die
politik ja leider gottes frieden jahres
lassen
sozialer wohnungsbau haben wir immer
mehr ab mittlerweile werden zwar wieder
viele sozialwohnungen oder geförderte
wohnungen gebaut aber es ist immer noch
viel zu wenig an der stelle
es gibt auch berechnungen nachdem
zehntausende von von frankfurt anspruch
auf eine geförderte wohnung haben aber
leider noch gar nicht fahren sind also
da ist auch unser dringender appell an
die politik hier wesentlich in der
sozial- und geförderte wohnungen zu
schaffen und das passiert eben wirklich
nur ganz unten mal hat er den den markt
ja auch letztendlich sich selber
überlassen und hat nicht gesehen dass
immer mehr menschen darauf angewiesen
sind eine günstigere wohnung bereit
gestellt zu bekommen und viele menschen
haben ja jetzt schon die schwierigkeit
dass sie oft 40 prozent 50 prozent
manchmal sogar noch mehr von ihrem
haushaltseinkommen zahlen müssen für die
miete und da ist es dringend nötig dass
eben auch mehr geförderter wohnraum
vorhanden ist und zwar nicht nur für die
ärmsten der armen sondern das muss auch
weit bis in die mittelschicht hinein
reichen weil auch immer mehr
krankenschwestern polizisten auch
grundschullehrer nicht in der lage sind
sich eine bezahlbare wohnung ins
transport zu suchen
hier fragt übrigens jetzt noch mal nach
und fragt kann man vermieter dazu
zwingen einen drittel der wohnung sozial
zu vermieten auch dass vermieter
solarzellen auf das dach installieren
müssen vielleicht ja sogar bei
privatvermietern geht das erste mal
jetzt so nicht bei bei städtischen
wohnungsgesellschaften da gibt es ja
regelungen wie hoch der anteil für
sozial beziehungsweise geförderte
wohnung sein soll wäre natürlich auch
sinnvoll zu überlegen ob man an der
stelle auch private familie
da in die pflicht nehmen kann man kann
das ganze jahr gegebenenfalls auch über
entsprechende förderprogramme dann
lenken so dass es auch für
privatvermieter interessant wird dort
auch in dem bereich zu investieren
in deutschland ist sehr einzel vermieter
getrieben also es gibt ganz erstaunlich
viele kleinvermieter gar nicht so sehr
viele große investoren oder große
wohnungsgesellschaften sondern eben auch
jetzt noch überhaupt nie wieder genannt
und für die er ist das natürlich nicht
was sie tun und ist in vielen bereich
natürlich auch finanziell unattraktiv
und da ist natürlich zu überlegen
inwiefern die politik da anreize
schaffen könnte um auch in dem bereich
der förderungen auch für die vermieter
dann zu geben damit sie auch in dem
bereich mehr investieren und quartieren
hatte neben normalen ja auch da ist es
natürlich erforderlich dass mehr
förderprogramme erfolgen damit eben auch
noch mehr vermied auch private vermieter
photovoltaikanlagen zum beispiel auf
offenere dann errichten damit dort eben
auch die möglichkeit besteht preiswerten
strom dann auch für die mieter zum
beispiel zu bekommen genau das geht eben
nur über anreize nicht das geht nur über
anreize wäre natürlich denkbar aber
sicherlich nicht hilfreich das hilft
weder den vermietern noch den gegnern
angestellten dann haben wir eine frage
von deines fahrgast er fragt in einem
angespannten wohnungsmarkt
wie sehen sie den bedarf nach dem
wohnberechtigungsschein von seiten des
firmen
vermieter und versuchen wir sehr häufig
in letzter zeit also dass das ist auch
so dieses thema was wird von mietern
eigentlich gefördert wenn sie eine
wohnung anbieten das liegt ja
mittlerweile vermieter die verlangen
geradezu ja so also eine art
bewerbungsmappe die die mieter
mitbringen sollen um zu zeigen wir sind
ein kommen sie haben dann dass sie dass
sie keine mietschulden haben das sind
geregeltes einkommen was auch immer und
das geht ja auch so ein bisschen in die
richtung das problem ist ist natürlich
dass hierdurch immer mehr mieter ins
abseits gedrängt werden wenn viele
familien besondere anforderungen stellen
bei wohnberechtigungsschein es ist jetzt
natürlich auch eine sache der verwaltung
wie sie dann damit umgeht
viele vermieter sagen sich auch ich
entscheide selber welche miete richter
nehme und jemanden mit wohn rechnung
schreiben möchte ich da nicht das ist
wie gesagt eben sehr schwierig das
allgemein vor die klammer gezogen wer
hat anspruch überhaupt auch in aktion
www es scheint ja das sind menschen mit
einem geringen einkommen das bis zu
einer gewissen grenze
reicht damit sie eine entsprechende
wohnberechtigungsschein bekommen das
müssen sagen da der behörde erfragen und
können darüber versuchen dann eine
wohnung zu bekommen und das sind aber je
nach region können dass man sehr sehr
viele seien habe ich in berlin situation
und die franzosen wären es ja auch
letztendlich relativ viele menschen die
die eine solche berechtigung bekommt in
ländlichen gegenden ist das natürlich
wesentlich wählen ein user hat noch
einen persönlichen fall zum thema
mietminderung in dem hof unser
angemieteten wohnung haben wir vom
gleichen vermieter eine garage
eingemietet seit etwa sechs monaten sind
dort 40 bis 50 cm tiefe schlaglöcher
kann man deshalb die miete mindern und
wenn ja wie viel kommt auch hier
wirklich auf den einzelfall an ob durch
diese schlagwörter zum beispiel die
zufahrt die nutzbarkeit der der garage
eingestellt ist also dass man das
fahrzeug jetzt vielleicht gar nicht mehr
gefahrlos in die garage reinbringen kann
150 cm sind das passt das bedeutet
eigentlich wird man zum beispiel mit dem
auto gar nicht mehr da
da richtig ran fahren können ich denke
also eine mietminderung halte ich hier
keinesfalls für ausgeschlossen aber was
eigentlich noch viel wichtiger wäre dass
der vermieter aufgefordert wird diesen
mangel zu beheben
denn das netz ist ein wird zum beispiel
wenn man eine mietwohnung auch
vielleicht für die garage selber bin zu
100 prozent den weil man die garage
nicht mehr nutzen kann
man möchte ja eigentlich dass die gras
wieder genutzt werden also hier sollte
man neben der mieten um den winter auf
jeden fall unter fristsetzung auffordern
dass diese schnell beseitigt also da wie
den schriftlichen
brief aufsetzen deutlich diese angriffe
die ja also das heißt sich optimal auf
den mangel an also hier in dem konkreten
fall würde ich sagen eine fristsetzung
von 14 tagen zum beispiel soll hier
ausreichend der vermieter windes zwar
vielleicht nicht schaffen innerhalb von
14 tagen die schlaglöcher zu beseitigen
aber er sollte zumindest innerhalb von
14 tagen mitteilen welche weiteren
schritte allerdings an nicht richtig wir
haben
[Musik]
ich wollte nochmal schwenken zum thema
sanierung
das ist ja auch immer wieder eine
situation die mieter sehr hilflos macht
also ein vermieter möchte eine wohnung
möchte seine wohnung wieder flott machen
erstens der mieter hat das problem mit
dem bauherrn mit mit schmutz und dreck
und gleichzeitig dann später eben mit
über mögliche höheren mieten
die ist da die gemengelagen da muss man
unterscheiden ob es sich um eine reine
sanierungsmaßnahmen also instandhaltung
reparatur maßnahme handelt da darf der
vermieter grundsätzlich die miete nicht
erhöhen oder ob eine moderne
die maßnahme also zwei kleine wohnwert
verletzungen vorliegen
in beiden fällen ist es oft so dass
solche massnahmen wochen monate manchmal
sogar noch länger dauern und es zu
erheblichen beeinträchtigung der
wohnwert qualität führen grundsätzlich
kann man in solchen film dann an eine
mietminderung denken und die richtet
sich also die höhe richtet sich im
prinzip danach wie hoch die
beeinträchtigung ist das können szenen
20 30 prozent zum teil auch noch mehr
sein weil wir genau im vorfeld sparen
können weil sie eben diesen ganzen dreck
und lernen sind tragen oder auch zum
beispiel das gerüst was was vor dem was
der wohnung dann steht so dass man die
fenster nicht mehr oder nur noch zum
teil
dass man keine balkone die nicht mehr
genutzt werden können dass das führt
dazu dass man zum teil recht hohe miet
meldungen ansatz bringen vielleicht hier
auf noch mal der hinweis also gerne
können sie auch natürlich weiterhin die
fragen über facebook stellen aber sie
auch gerne alle nicht gibt nochmal die
nummern durch die 0 69 75 91 24 550 da
hinten sitzen wahnsinnig anwälte die
sich freuen ihre fragen entgegen zu
nehmen
leute die eben auch schon jahrelange
erfahrung haben im mietrecht und
wohnungseigentumsrecht also da sind sie
hat sie eingeladen auch bilateral dinge
zu klären
aber jetzt kommen wir mal wird sie eine
regel userin es gab mal einen iwf
scheinen also ein
wohnberechtigungsschein für mieter die
zwar ein gutes einkommen haben aber zu
viele personen im zu kleinen wohnraum
gilt dies heute nicht mehr
da sollte man bei der zuständigen bürger
erfahren das könnte ich jetzt im moment
nicht genau was man aber oft eher als
problem hat ist dass man mal einen
wohnberechtigungsschein hatte verliert
man den verliert man irgendwann also gut
bzw
der wird dann und dann relevant wenn man
auf wohnungssuche erscheinen
grundsätzlich dann und ist natürlich
auch einkommensabhängig dann wäre also
es kann ja sein dass während des
laufenden
verfahrens der wohnungssuche sich dann
schwankungen ergeben
das müsste man mit der behörde
letztendlich ist es aber es umgekehrt so
dass wenn man einmal quasi in eine in
eine günstige wohnung gekommen ist über
so einen prächtigen schein ist es nicht
so dass man ausziehen wenn sich die kann
man natürlich dann also darf man als
mitarbeiter wurden das ist das insofern
eigentlichen ein weiteres problem wie
würden sie das sehen dass zur
wohnungsknappheit
das wird ja immer auch gerne ins feld
geführt dass im grunde noch viele
niedrigpreisen wohnungen belagert werden
von von menschen die einmal dass man für
nötig halten aber jetzt vielleicht
herausgewachsen sind und jetzt ist das
einkommen haben und womöglich eine
andere wohnung leisten können aber
natürlich auch erholung nicht verlassen
aber dass das das ist ein umstand
allerdings muss man auch sehen die
wohnungsnot die die besteht darf
natürlich jetzt nicht auf dem rücken
derjenigen die einmal über dieses modell
dann eine wohnung bekommen haben dann
ausgetragen werden selbstverständlich
ist die politik weiterhin in der pflicht
weitere bezahlbare wohnungen zu schaffen
und wir sagen ja auch immer bezahlbar
ist eine wohnung dann wenn ein mieter
nicht mehr als etwa 30 prozent seines
monatlichen haushaltseinkommen es für
die miete aufwenden
das ist ja gerade bei niedrigen
einkommen dann oft recht schwierig wenn
ihr jemand zum beispiel 1500 euro
haushaltseinkommen az er nicht mehr als
etwa 500 euro dann für die mieter wenn
das macht das dann schon in frankfurt
recht schwierig eine eine bezahlbare
wohnung für eine familie zum beispiel
dann zu bekommen für jemanden der fünf
oder sechs 1000 euro netto verdient wir
können sich die 30 prozent finanzieren
natürlich ganz anders aus aber die 30
prozent würden die st
gelten immer noch also sollte man sich
als pi mal daumen regel ja sind kraft
bank erhalten sie eigentlich besonders
wichtig als appell an die politik dass
dort in gesehen wird wenn wenn wohnung
in frankfurt auch von der städtischen
wohnungsgesellschaft für 12 13 euro pro
quadratmeter oder mehr sogar zum teil
vermietet werden bedeutet das ja dass
man für eine dreizimmerwohnung 70 80
quadratmeter gut 1000 euro kaltmiete
zahlt dann kommen noch die nebenkosten
hinzu dann ist man bei 12 13 100 euro
miete
etwa die hälfte der frankfurter
bevölkerung haben wir ein monatliches
nettohaushaltseinkommen von 2000 euro
oder weniger
da sieht man in welchem verhältnis dann
die die mietkosten stehen gerade eben
auch bei neu errichtet wurden und auch
vom städtischen wohnungsgesellschaften
und wie hoch die finanziellen
möglichkeiten der mieter sind oder der
überwindung wiedersehen und das zeigt
dass immer mehr wohnungen auch gebaut
werden müssten dies eben auch ermöglicht
dass die überwiegende anzahl der mieter
in frankfurt nicht mehr als etwa 30
prozent zahlen müssen was bedeutet das
eben auch drei zimmer wohnungen für 600
700 euro brutto vorhanden sind und davon
gibt es leider das ziel zu werden
das schöne dass man sich auch das schöne
das kuriose dass man sich tatsächlich
für wohnung gewehr muss sie haben es
vorhin schon ein bisschen erwähnt als
mann
man muss mit lebenslauf einkommen was
wirklich vergleich das eigentlich
manchmal ganz gerne mit dem autokauf
stellen sie sich vor sie wollten einen
autokauf mit einer bewerbungsmappe ins
auto aus um zu zeigen dass das sind ganz
toll sind um ein auto sich kaufen zu
können
das wäre absurd der wohnungen gerade so
dass ganz existenzielle wird aber sehr
oft von vermietern verlangt dass man
einen gewissen jahr
datenschutzrechtlichen striptease einer
durchführen muss indem man auch
persönliche daten offen licht lee den
vermieter zumindest vor abschluss eines
mietvertrages nichts angehen leider
gottes sehen sich immer mehr mieter wird
dazu veranlasst gerade auch wenn sie im
internet über wohnungen sich auf die
wohnungssuche machen dass sie dort sehr
viele persönliche daten offenlegen und
uns drei gehen um überhaupt dann in die
nächste ebene zu kommen damit sie dort
als potenzieller interessent dann auch
vom vermieter wagen also das ist die
nackte gemacht praktischen aber was sind
der nacht für kuriose fragen führen
vielleicht sondern unverschämte fragen
in der praxis schon mal aufgeladen zu
sagen sie mietern hier wirklich bei
aller liebe sollte man das also es gibt
es gibt natürlich weniger bei
wohnungsgesellschaften aber der
privatvermieter dann eben auch sehr
persönliche fragen die es zum beispiel
auch noch der sexuellen ausrichtung
nachfragen da sagen natürlich auch klar
als als vermieter
als mieter mut immer da nicht die
wahrheit seien nur etwas sagen müsste
man schon denn dort ist man völlig außen
außen vor
fragen auch zum beispiel ob man
haustiere hat und ob man häufig besucht
hat und es wird alles mögliche dort ab
gefragt wo man sich eben denkt na ja
eigentlich wird hier schon sehr viel in
die persönlichkeitssphäre der hat man
das recht zu lügen
welche fragen sich das bezieht also man
hat nicht das recht zu lügen wenn es um
die um die finanziellen verhältnisse
geld also wenn man jetzt mit seinem
gehalt zum beispiel falsche unterlagen
über sein gehalt nicht also also falsche
abrechnungs belege das dürfte man nicht
machen also dann könnte auch der
vermieter sein das ist ein grund für
eine fristlose kündigung
aber man darf zum beispiel auch die in
wahrheit sagen wenn es um das thema geht
und sie schwanger ist ziemlich lange und
eben auch nach was haben sie vor
demnächst zu heiraten oder nicht das
geht den vermieter nichts an und wir
haben noch eine frage zum thema
mieterhöhung von hagens wolf der fakt
der vermieter kann die miete so lange
eigentlich im bisher auf dem
ortsüblichen ist in welchen zeiträumen
und welchen prozent schritten kann
maximal tod ja also da gibt es folgende
regelungen innerhalb von drei jahren
darf die miete nicht mehr als hier in
frankfurt 15 prozent steigen also da
gibt es in regel mit bundesweit 120
prozent 15 prozent hier in bestimmten
städten wie frankfurt gleichzeitig muss
man aber auch schauen dass die linke
liegt über die ortsübliche
vergleichsmiete nicht also bei einem
mieterhöhungsverlangen muss man deswegen
prüfen wie hoch ist eigentlich die
ortsübliche vergleichsmiete das heißt in
frankfurt würde man hingehen
in einem ordnungen als beispiel wenn die
ortsübliche vergleichsmiete bei 800 euro
liegt jetzt zahlt man zum beispiel 500
euro
dann könnte der vermieter eigentlich auf
diese ortsüblich vergleichsmiete ihn
aber er darf ja nicht mehr als 15
prozent innerhalb von drei jahren
erhöhen und das verheißt über 500 sind
wir bei 550 euro wenn ich richtung
verläuft auf 650 euro er dürfte nicht
aufgehen auf die ortsübliche
vergleichsmiete angehen umgekehrt wäre
es so wenn die miete jetzt schon 700
euro beträgt dann könnte der future dann
könnte der vermieter auf die 800 euro
gehen weil er dann ja nicht die 50
prozent überschreiten werden deswegen
muss man mehrere rechenschritte
durchgehen ich danke auch für die kammer
gezwungen die ortsübliche
vergleichsmiete was verbirgt sich denn
da hinter dir und das ist die jede die
für eine vergleichbare wohnung
vergleichbar mit dem gesehen die lage
die ausstattung der wohnung in der
kommune in der gemeinde verlangt wird in
einer stadt wie frankfurt gibt es dafür
den qualifizierten mietspiegel dort kann
man seine wohnung dann heim orten
aufgrund der größe der wohnung der bau
altersklasse
dann gibt es noch zu und abschläge für
den zuschnitt der wohnung für die
ausstattung der wohnung wenn man diesen
rechenschritt durchgeführt hat dann
kommt man zu einem quadratmeterpreis
monat und hat dann die ortsübliche
vergleichsmiete in städten in denen es
so einen spiegel liegt gibt wird das mit
vergleichswohnungen beziehungsweise
sachverständigengutachten dann ermittelt
das heißt der vermieter muss wenn er
eine mieterhöhung stellen will
dieses begründen dass moser machen mit
vergleichswohnungen einem
sachverständigen-gutachten oder den
mietspiegel wenn es an qualifizierten
mietspiegel
in frankfurt muss der familie jedenfalls
auch den mietspiegel anführen und die
wohnen nur drei noten manche vermieter
machen sind nämlich so auch in frankfurt
die fälle habe ich auch schon gehabt
dass sie dann drei vergleichswohnungen
manchmal aus dem eigenen land angeben
wann immer noch aus dem eigenen haus
also wenn der vermieter zum beispiel
zehn wohnungen in einem haus hat dann
nimmt er dann manchmal szenen neu
vermietete wohnungen sagt die sind ja
alle im selben haus und jetzt sagen die
mieter hd und die miete ist ja aber das
wäre nicht zulässig aber sie glauben gar
nicht wie viele nette darauf den darauf
hereinfallen ja leider gottes
da macht sich ein mieter ja auch erst
mal keine gedanken
naja andere mieter im selben haus zahlen
ja dann eben eine höhere winter gut dann
ist das wohl die augen vergleichsmiete
hier für diese liegenschaft dann muss
ich auch dementsprechend die mieter wird
vor dem hintergrund rat gegeben
hinter der eine mieterhöhung erhält auf
jeden fall dies überprüfen zu lassen
denn wenn man der mieterhöhung einmal
zugestimmt hat kommt man dass man erst
mal nicht rund wir übrigens zum qualität
den findet man auch im internet wien ein
event das kann man relativ leichter nach
und danach prüfen und demnächst gibt es
ja auch einen neuen mitspieler für 2018
wer jetzt gilt ja noch bis zum einen
rassisten meinen wäre mir zwei fragen
von usern zur modernisierung und
reparaturen
eine dame fragt muss ich wenn ich aus
tier aus einer alten wohnung die ist
einfach 50 jahre alt war etwa 30 jahren
nicht saniert die fugen neu machen wenn
er hausverwalter das verlangt welche
schönheitsreparaturen sind überhaupt
standard aber vielleicht zunächst zu
diensten
eine rechtliche grundlage dass die
niederinnen das machen muss denn das
gehört dazu nicht fähig nicht weiter zur
instandsetzung instandhaltung nach dem
gesetz ist das aufgabe des vermieters
diese arbeiten durchzuführen was die
schönheitsreparaturen anbelangt das in
der steigung und tapezierarbeiten da
sollte die sie drin sich genau dem
mietvertrag anschauen vor allem genau
überprüfen lassen ob hier wirksame
regelung
vorliegend ob sie tatsächlich auch bei
auszug die strafe die arbeiten
durchführen muss wenn es sich um einen
älteren mietvertrag handel spricht viel
dafür dass du das vielleicht nicht
machen muss denn es gibt sehr viele
formular klauseln in mietverträgen ist
von der rechtsprechung gekippt worden
sind er nach dem gesetz sieht es ja so
aus dass der vermieter die stein und
tapezierarbeiten durch gewusst das ist
teil der instandsetzung sind stand
haltungs maßnahmen der vermieter muss
das machen nur wenn im mietvertrag
wirksam vereinbart worden ist dass der
mieter diese arbeiten durchführen muss
dann muss es dann wieder man aber wir
raten jedem mieter lassen sie ihren
mietvertrag der offenen überprüfen genau
das ist ein wichtiger hinweis denn
insbesondere bei älteren also die schon
zehn 15 jahre alt sind
denn es gab eine welle von
gerichtsurteil er höchstinstanzlich vom
bundesgerichtshof die sind jetzt fünf
sechs sieben jahre her
wenn ich das rötliche wiederholt immer
wieder neue die reihenweise klauseln
gekippt standard klauseln in
mietverträgen standardmäßig verwendet
und wie gesagt haben diese gehen zu
lasten des mieters sind deswegen
unzulässig und werden dann einfach
ersatzlos gestrichen das heißt es gibt
daneben keine klausel zum thema schön
langsam greift die gesetzliche regelung
und die wiederum sagt jetzt vermieter
ist verfliegt also auch wenn schwarz auf
weiß im mietvertrag steht dass der
mieter die schönheitsreparaturen
durchführen muss um selbst jüngsten
greift das nicht dann haben wir hier
noch eine weitere frage ist der
vermieter zu reparaturen am haus
verpflichtet wie zum beispiel ein
verrottetes eingangstor in stand zu
setzen
und wie bringt man ihnen dazu kann ein
vermieter einen baum der porsches und
tot umzufallen fällen lassen und die
kosten komplett auf die mieter um
also vielleicht zunächst zu dem
eingangstor hier kann ja auch durchaus
gefahr bei der nutzung dieses tores
besteht verletzungsgefahr zum beispiel
auch da sie es durchaus die
verpflichtung des vermieters diese
reparaturarbeiten durchführen zu lassen
also hier auch sollte man den vermieter
am besten schriftlich mit fristsetzung
auffordern dies zu machen was den baum
anbelangt also wenn die gefahr besteht
dass das der baum umkippt dass er
gefällt werden muss sich erst mal keine
rechtliche grundlage warum der mieter
sich an den kosten zu beteiligen hätte
denkbar wäre ich hier dass man auf
vermieterseite vielleicht versuchen
wollte das über die
betriebskostenabrechnungen bei den
garten pflegekosten zu machen aber dabei
ist sehr umstritten baumfäll kosten
wirklich erforderlich sind
denn bei den garten pflegekosten sind
regelmäßig nur regelmäßig wiederkehrende
kosten zu tragen wenn es sich aber um
einen kranken morschen baum handelt
gegen es ja mehr um den bereich
instandsetzung instandhaltung also im
konkreten fall gehe ich davon aus dass
die baumfällarbeiten vom vermieter zu
graben wird eingeschaltet haben herzlich
willkommen zu unserem
faz live leseraktion wie gesagt den hier
im hintergrund anwälte die ihn fragen zu
mieterhöhungen zu kündigungen zu
eigenbedarf beantworten sind herzlich
eingeladen
da angerufen und dann nur der 0 69 75 91
24 50 ansonsten sitze ich hier mit rolf
janssen geschäftsführer frank wurde mit
verein wir sind wie gesagt jetzt in die
zweite hälfte und sie können noch fragen
stellen entweder auf youtube oder auf
facebook ist gerne bereit ad hoc alle
fragen zu beantworten
vielleicht vorfeld noch bevor jetzt
weitere fragen um einmal die frage was
denn passiert wenn man tatsächlich klagt
wie häufig kommt das vor lässt sich
viele schon im vorfeld regeln und was
muss der mieter rechnen wenn er
tatsächlich vor gericht siegen möchte
also vielleicht kurz vorweg etwa 97
prozent aller fälle die wir beraten
werden außergerichtlich geklärt
da liegen wir auch ganz großen 97
fast alle also es kommt relativ selten
vor dass streitigkeiten dann vor gericht
ausgetragen
das ist dann der fall wenn es zum
beispiel das mietverhältnis beendet ist
und der vermieter die kaution nicht
herausgibt allerdings auch im laufenden
mietverhältnis wenden wenn der vermieter
sich partout weigert zum beispiel
mängeln der mietsache zu beginn
unser anliegen ist ja auch dass die
mietverhältnisse man ist ja oftmals
viele jahren mit dem vermieter in einem
mietwert ist dass die gedeihliche und
harmonisch laufen und die meisten mieter
möchten ja auch gar nicht das dass sie
sich vor im gericht medienwirksam etat
wiedersehen sondern wollen eine
außergerichtliche klärung haben und den
allermeisten fällen klappt das auch in
den fällen in denen allerdings dann an
ausdrückliche erklärung nicht möglich
ist haben zum beispiel unsere mitglieder
an den wirtschafts beitrag eine
rechtsschutzversicherung enthalten so
dass dann auch die weg schutz
versicherungen dann einen solchen
prozess übernehmen kann
die es ist kommt darauf an bei der länge
des prozesses um was für ein verfahren
sg zum beispiel bei kündigung
streitigkeiten können sich solche
verfahren über monate auch jahre
hinziehen
andere streitigkeiten wir zum beispiel
bei bei nebenkosten abrechnungen oder
auch bei kautions rückzahlungen können
deutlich kürzer abgeschlossen werden
aber dass da kann man im prinzip nicht
sagen also der thematik hat man eine
prozessdauer von so viel monat das ist
wirklich ganz und gar vom einst
verbunden nicht wir haben noch alle der
meint der wohnungsmarkt wird absichtlich
knapp gehalten um billige baumasse teuer
verkaufen zu können
folgen sie eine große pendlerverkehr
strömung und gentrifizierung wie sehen
sie das
wir wollen natürlich nicht hoffen dass
der wohnungsmarkt künstlich knapp
gehalten wird von unterschiedlichen
interessen wichtig ist ja dass das dass
er geöffnet
frankfurt ist ja eine sehr wachsende
stand und wir werden ja auch in den
nächsten jahren jahrzehnten noch einen
deutlichen zuwachs in frankfurt erleben
und frankfurt alleine wird es auch wohl
nicht schaffen dass im stadtgebiet von
frankfurt genügend wohnungen errichtet
das ist natürlich ganz wichtig dass
jetzt nicht nur dass das im umland
gebaut werden sondern natürlich auch in
der stadt frankfurt selber aber es ist
im prinzip eine gemeinschaftsarbeit
zwischen der staatskanzlei und dem
umland damit eben den pendlern und auch
den zuziehenden hier in frankfurt
genügend wohnraum zur verfügung gestellt
das gilt ja auch gerade im hinblick auf
dem brett auch da kann es ja durchaus
sein dass eine größere anzahl von
menschen aus england dann hier nach
frankfurt kommen und nach wohnraum
[Musik]
warum ist das so viel dass sich die
politik so schwer war das sind sozusagen
die hirn die sie überspringen muss um
auf dem weg zum zu mehr mehr wohnraum zu
kostengünstigeren in innerstaatliches
antwort ist natürlich der wohnraum also
wenn man jetzt die größe von frankfurt
an sieht schon durchaus knapp
eingeschränkt aber es gibt ja auch
möglichkeiten ja zum teil jetzt auch
genutzt werden
auch innerhalb des stadtgebietes zum
beispiel durch nachverdichtung neuen
wohnraum zu schaffen wobei die form der
nachverdichtung ist ja
hat er recht besonderen schwierigkeiten
zu tun denn man muss sich ja immer
darüber im klaren sein in den quartieren
in denen eine nachverdichtung erfolgt da
wurden ja schon menschen
diese menschen sind mit monate
jahrelange baumaßnahmen konfrontiert und
haben hinterher auch wenn jetzt neue
mieter in die liegenschaften einziehen
ganz andere schwierigkeiten zu
bewältigen
dann sind auf einmal gemeinschaftsräume
wie waschräumen und trockenräume nur
noch eingeschränkt nutzbar
es ist auf einmal viel lauter im haus
weil jetzt nicht zehn sondern 20
mietparteien oder mehr dort wohnen aber
das auto auf der straße kann man
vielleicht nicht mehr parken weil jetzt
noch mehr leute dort ihre autos stehen
haben eine ganz schwierige situation
das muss man bei nachverdichtung
natürlich alles immer mit mit
einbeziehen
das sind ja probleme die man wenn man
jetzt auf der grünen wiese neue
wohnungen errichtet zum beispiel neun
größten stadtteil wie ihr ist ja jetzt
auch überlegt ist in der nähe von der
bundesautobahn 5 da hat man solche
schwierigkeiten nicht gut da hat man
andere probleme da natürlich zu
bewältigen
baurechtliche art insbesondere das ist
ihnen ganz große schwierigkeiten die
dort vorhanden sind gerade eben auch im
bereich des baurechts im umweltrecht die
die dazu führen dass es oft sehr sehr
lange gedauert bis dort neue baugebiete
ausgewiesen sind bzw auch nach
verdichtungen möglichst erwähnte beim
thema
doch einige spekulanten am werk sind da
wohnung oder sagen wir so grund kaufen
und das eben war stehen lassen ohne was
dann ganz gewissermaßen gehalten das ist
ein großes problem
das ist durchaus nimmt das dass die
stadt frankfurt da auch sozial die
potentiellen möglichkeiten die da wären
nicht voll ausnutzen kann weil es ihm
schwierig ist auch solche brachliegenden
grundstücke dann sinnvoll zu
bewirtschaften also dort eben auch
wohnungen zu errichten damit mehr
menschen dort ansieht
wir haben noch eine frage von berg wie
wird zum thema eigenbedarf das ist ja in
der tat auch wirklich ziemlich heißes
thema da haben wir auch einige urteile
schon dazu die die die voraussetzung für
vermieter da ein wenig gelockert haben
wie wird eigentlich ein bedarf geprüft
fragt er hier wird auf eigenbedarf
vorgeschoben um wohnungen teuer zu
verhüten und zu verkaufen
ja das thema eigenbedarfskündigung hat
in den letzten jahren bei uns doch
deutlich zugenommen und ich sage das
jetzt auch mal so ganz deutlich obwohl
sicherlich die kollegen von den
eigentümer verbände nicht so gerne hören
aber es ist leider so es wird auf
vermieterseite nirgendwo so viel
gemogelt ihrer eigenen erlebens sogar
relativ häufig dass wenn sich der mieter
und vermieter über ganz andere dinge wie
zb betriebskostenabrechnungen oder
mieterhöhungen gestritten haben und der
vermieter mit seinem anliegen sei man
sie nicht durchdringen kann das dann
relativ kurz danach eine
eigenbedarfskündigung kommt bei der man
sich wundert warum jetzt noch einmal
diese wunde verdient
wenn man an der eigenbedarfskündigung
hält sollte man deswegen sehr genau
prüfen ob die voraussetzungen auch
tatsächlich früher war das noch etwas
anders da war es tatsächlich so der
vermieter musste darlegen dass er die
wohnungen dringend benötigt um dort
selber diese weise eine nahestehende
person benötigen dort zu wohnen
das ist mittlerweile durch die
rechtsprechung sehr stark gelockert
worden so dass auch sie es nicht fern
geringere interessen des vermieters
mittlerweile ausreichend um eigenbedarf
der durchgehen zu lassen allerdings muss
man als oder sollte man wickelt als als
mieter prüfen ob ihr bin ich doch ganz
andere dinge hier eine rolle spielen als
der vorgetragene eigenbedarf und was wir
auch immer wieder sehen ganz wichtig ist
auch dass bei eigenbedarfskündigungen
die kündigungsfristen überprüft werden
gerade eben bei älteren mietverträgen
wir haben das ja oft so dass dort noch
verlängerte gründungsfesten manchmal
auch noch mit verlängerungsklausel fan
sind sodass kündigung manchmal erst in
einem abstand von 1 2 oder mehr jahren
möglich sind das sollte man als mieter
unbedingt prüfen weil dort auch auf
vermieterseite das nicht immer so genau
beachtet dann haben kommen wir langsam
zum schluss aber ein fall haben wir noch
an wolf beschreibt beim einzug in meine
letzte wohnung vor allem h
drei zimmer habe ich fußböden
fensterbänke und wenn der komplett
saniert dafür durfte ich einen monat
mietfrei wohnen meine kosten lagen bei
ca 8000 euro
kann ich diese nachträglich beim einem
liter einfordern
also vom vermieter das problem könnte
hier seien der vermieter hat ja zwar
einen monat mit freiheit gewährt aber
klar das steht in keinem verhältnis zu
den hohen kosten die vorhanden waren was
manche durchaus an was man sich
ausdenken könnte wäre aber dass man den
zeitwert in denen jetzt dieser einbau
jetzt noch hat dass man den gegenüber
dem vermieter geltend macht sonst wäre
es vielleicht ganz sinnvoll gewesen wenn
man zu beginn das mietwert das ist schon
im mietvertrag festgeschrieben hätte was
denn jetzt bei auszug dann mit einer
kosten kompensation aussieht ansonsten
könnte der vermieter compo sana ja
wieder du hast du die antworten zwar
durchgeführt aber eine eine kompensation
dafür gibt es jetzt nicht aber man
sollte versuchen ihn mit dem zeitwert
doch noch bzw
kann es ja auch durchaus sein dass der
vermieter das auch vielleicht auch schon
aus menschlichem moralischen gründen als
als angemessen ansieht dass er jetzt ja
diesen bisschen bodenbelag den er weiter
nutzen auch weiter vermieten kann dann
eben an den mieter dann kompetent
versuchen sollte man es wie gesagt wenn
man so viel auch außergerichtlich klären
kann vielleicht auch in bilateralen
gesprächen
das ist ein ganz afrika rationell trat
wir an der stelle immer also bewusst zu
einer auseinandersetzung kommt sollte
man wirklich zunächst versuchen mit dem
vermieter zu sprechen
da sind oftmals zu ganz vernünftige
lösungen möglich nur wenn man sieht der
vermieter lässt nicht mit sich sprechen
oder blockieren dann sollte man
natürlich schauen welche rechtlichen
möglichkeiten man durchsetzt dann haben
wir noch einen kommentar der uns über
youtube erreicht das natürlich auch
immer ein möglicher kanal warnung hagen
strahlt mit bewerbungen die nur der
absicherung des vermieters sind dieser
das höhere risiko trägt durchaus auch
bedenkzeit gibt es also seitens des
mieterschutzes alternative vorschläge
wie man vermieter mehr sicherheit geben
kann so das sogenannte mit bewerbung
unnötig werden also da ein wichtiger
hinweisen denn natürlich hat er gibt der
vermieter eine wohnung an wildfremde
menschen die ihr noch nie gesehen was da
ja oft mitschwingt ist ja auch dieses
thema mietnomaden
jetzt wird man ja gott sei dank in
letzter zeit nicht mehr so häufig diesen
begriff aber vor einigen jahren tauchte
das immer wieder auf man muss klar
darüber im klaren sein was ein
mietnomade ist ein lied normal ist ein
betrüger das ist jemand der eine wohnung
anmietet und von vorneherein nicht nicht
wind
das defizit kann hat er ist nicht bereit
in liezen zu zahlen und will dort
umsonst wo dass er ein betrüger ein
mietnomade ist nicht niemand der die
miete nicht zahlt weil die wohnung
mangelhaft ist oder der die
betriebskosten nachforderungen nicht
zahlt weil die nebenkostenabrechnung
fehlerhaft ist oder die wohnung verlässt
ohne schönheitsreparaturen durchgeführt
haben weil er das nach dem mietvertrag
nicht muss der begriff mit normale wird
auf vermieterseite manchmal anders nutzt
selbstverständlich nachvollziehbar dass
vermieter sagen wir möchten gewisse
sicherheiten haben
aber es dürfte durchaus ausreichen wenn
der vermieter vermieter verlangt zum
beispiel die vorlage der letzten drei
gehaltsabrechnungen das zeigt ja schon
da fließt geld das zeigt wie lange
besteht das arbeitsverhältnis es ist
eigentlich ein hinreichender und
umgekehrt muss man ja auch sagen
der mieter war es letztendlich auch
nicht auf wen er sich einlässt wenn sie
wurden anbietet welchen vermieter er in
die hände bekommt
da kann es auch passieren dass er auf
einmal kein ansprechpartner hat weil
weil der vermieter umgezogen ist und
seine neue adresse nicht wiedergibt das
kann auch schwierigkeiten aber ich denke
die vorlage von gehaltsnachweise ist
schon eine ahnung
dann haben wir doch fragen zur thema
mietpreis bremse clemens könig fragt wie
stark vermuten sie wird sich der nächste
wirtschaftliche abschwung auf die mieten
in den hochpreisigen vorstellen wie zum
beispiel wünschen auswirken
das wird die frage jetzt dann wir mal ob
durch die mikros bremse möglicherweise
investitionsrechnung das war kann ich
mir preisgeben sondern ging es wirklich
nur um die entwicklung der mietpreise
perspektive schätzt wahrscheinlich
immerhin de auch die umgekehrt jetzt
diesen hohen die preise auch mit dem
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung dem zu
verdanken habe und auch zu erwarten dass
die preise auch wieder sinken
also wir sehen im moment nicht dass sie
singt und zwar so lange dort keine keine
kappung keine begrenzung stattfindet
werden natürlich viele vermieter sich
sagen ich möchte was auch verstehen
nicht möglichst viel rendite mit mit
meiner wohnung erlangen und wenn ich
sehe dass der nachbar seine wohnung
vermietet das für teures geld macht
warum sollte ich das nicht auch machen
deswegen hatten wir es schon für
sinnvoll dass dort hier auch in diesem
markt eingegriffen wird auch wenn
vermieter oft sagen dass das den
eingriff in die vertragsfreiheit es sind
sie ja so viele eingriffe die aber doch
dazu führen dass doch die sehr
schwierige und angespannte situation auf
dem wohnungsmarkt verbessert werden muss
denn es gibt immer mehr mieter die
größte schwierigkeit namen eine wohnung
zu bekommen und wenn ein mieter jetzt
nach frankfurt kommt und eine bezahlbare
wohnung gesucht dann nützt ihm nichts
wenn zwei oder drei jahren vielleicht
eine solche wohnung gebaut denn er
braucht sie jetzt und deswegen ist es
jetzt erforderlich dass wir eine
wirksame die pasta
wir haben doch einen kommentar zum thema
neubau christian wolff kommentiert meine
des baum ist auch keine lösung wenn
später die nötigen kitas kindergärten
und schulen werden sollte schon ein
stimmiges konzept durchgesetzt
das ist vollkommen richtig deswegen ist
es ja auch gerade so schwierig große
neubaugebiete mit so zu konzipieren dass
eben nicht nur viele wohnungen dastehen
sondern die ganze infrastruktur muss
fahren seien also nicht nur die die
straßen wege sondern kindertagesstätten
ärzte apotheken schulen alles muss
vorhanden sein damit das ganze ein ein
homogenes und geschlossenes ganzes gibt
aber das sind natürlich planungen die
viele jahre an sternen
deswegen ist es ja so schwierig auf auf
die schnelle gewissermaßen eine große
anzahl von wohnungen zu schaffen
gut dann sind wir jetzt kommen wir zum
ende wir danken ganz herzlich für die
regelt eine für die fragen kommentare
die es gegeben hat sie können sich hier
noch weiter informieren wie gesagt
unsere experten im hintergrund am
telefon stehen hier noch eine weitere
stunde zur verfügung bis 16 uhr
ich sag noch gerne noch mal die nummer
ist die neue 6 975 einen neuen sich 24
15 alle informationen zum thema
mietrecht finden sie auch bei uns nett
und in der frankfurter allgemeinen
sonntagszeitung und in der tageszeit auf
das hätte allgemeine zeitung sowie auf
einspruch unser neues online-magazin
dass ich vor allen dingen um rechtliche
dinge kümmern da sehr starken fokus
drauf hat vielleicht können sie das was
ich einfach mal im internet also gucken
wir bedanken uns ganz ganz herzlich
herzlichen dank auch an seinen gänsen
dass sie hier erfragen und antwort so
wunderbar über sich ergehen haben wird
jetzt klar sagen aber dass sie diese
wunderbar mitgemacht haben wir wünschen
noch einen schönen sonnigen sonntag und
einen schönen start in die woche
herzlichen dank